Hey Youtubers It's Charlie so we got a new
Flarrow trailer I'm going to break it down
and we have info on the midseason finale's
for arrow and the flash so let's get going.
The thing that this different from last year
is that like the entire cast from the flash
will go on arrow during the flash episode
Vandal Savage comes after Hawkgirl when she's
with Cisco Cisco takes her to star labs explains
that everyone how he buys on her in they go
to all of her in team arrow for help when
they're in Star city Hawkman comes out of
nowhere and steals off with Hawkgirl now at
this point in the story she has no idea who
she is like you just hang out with Cisco just
thinking she's a regular barista
so he has explained to her what their heritage
is the whole idea of reincarnation the fact
that she has wings she can fly so it's about
her figuring out that she has his powers as
you see from the trailer in addition there
is some zoom stuff happening in the episode
itself is called legends of the day the arrow
part of the crossover is called legends of
yesterday to get the idea it's a play on the
title legends of tomorrow of zoom stuff is
happening on the flash part of it's really
cold this'll freak you guys out Harrison wells
comes up with another speed serum that will
allow Barry to run faster but he wants to
test it out on Jay Garrick first now doesn't
that just scream Edward Clariss from the classic
Golden age flash comics now in case you didn't
read comics during the Jay Garrick era the
reverse flash of his era was named Edward
Clariss he developed the serum that allowed
him to run as fast as the flash so he became
what was known as the rival later in the comics
that character looked like a shadow version
of Jay Garrick with blue lightning so just
add that to your list of zoom theories like
a dark version of Jay Garrick but on the arrow
part of the crossover team arrow team flash
take Hawkman in Hawkgirl to another secret
location to hide out from Vandal Savage get
Merlyn's help Merlyn isn't going to just sit
on the bench during the two hour crossover
he ends up being a go-between for Vandal Savage
the wall that's all going down Laurel Diggle
via Felicity and the other people from team
flash develop a weapon to take down Vandal
Savage or Liz neutralize them because he's
going to be the big bad for legends of tomorrow
so that I can be able to kill him the real
question is is what does Vandal Savage walked
in Hawkgirl so bad that he attacks her in
the first part of the crossover my thought
is is what they've done is because he's a
mortal Hawkman Hawkgirl essentially moral
too early think it keep getting reincarnated
that he wants her and metal for those that
haven't read any Hawkman Hawkgirl comics the
nth metal is this fan a guardian mineral that
their gear is made up it has a bunch of magical
properties allows them to fly it just is the
most amazing metal he could ever imagine next
to dwarf star alloy to be the Vandal Savage
could be after that orchid has something to
do with the curse of reincarnation that they
changed Hawkman Hawkgirl's backstory is a
little bit across the comics so I'm just assuming
that the gonna dovetail Vandal Savage with
their origin story here's my big question
if you guys let me know in the comments below
what do you think that Vandal Savage wants
from Hawkgirl do you think it's the nth metal
that he wants or is it something else but
in addition to whatever temporary victory
they when he gets Vandal Savage I'm expecting
a rip hunter cameo at the end and I think
that legends of tomorrow is going to start
episode one whenever arrow and flash come
back in January that you like the third week
in January this of the shows going to start
at the beginning of the year that just that
makes the most sense and pry just it on a
different night that show is only supposed
to be like 13 to 16 episodes but they haven't
decided exactly how many episodes it's going
to be was can happen next is because arrow
flash on break next week but there's heroes
and villains fan Fest this weekend Stephen
Amell said they're bringing something extra
cool I think they're going to debut new footage
so next week all totally do a video for whatever
new trailer footage they bring and you guys
haven't heard me talk avid talk about all
week Jessica Jones is dropping midnight tonight
I'll be doing all kinds of crazy videos to
be sure to subscribe to get everything and
I might do one last Jessica Jones trailer
video I have a whole bunch of footage I do
like one last video before the Sears premieres
I don't know internationally I'm not sure
what time it's gonna drop internationally
so if you live in Great Britain or live in
Australia or somewhere else I'm not exactly
sure seems that the double check on the time
while you guys wait for everything to post
you can click here for the this week's episode
of arrow and the flash and you can click here
for the star wars trailer I just posted. Whole
bunch of Finn Lightsaber action, it's so awesome.
Thank you so much for watching, everybody
let's high five and I'll see you guys tonight!